seyton please no more happy wills videos
I can't take any more I can't take it
anymore
Oh what's this guts and glory there's a
game that you probably haven't heard of
it seems pre-alpha that means I'm cool
for playing it and you can suck it
that was too far he posted some stuff on
reddit it looks hilarious and we're
gonna check it out
movement arrow keys and WASD oh my lord
come on little Timmy was that your name
okay we got it we gotta get you to
school boy which is in oh my god what
the [ __ ] didn't know that was possible
alright come on Timmy we're gonna go
fast oh oh oh [ __ ] I didn't see it
alright here we go
backflip holy [ __ ]
that was awesome I got moved son now we
gotta jump over this yes just as planned
boy
Oh No
hey make us attack decapitated try that
again
Oh slow jesus [ __ ] christ his head we
got to get you to school boy they're at
it go fast slow motion press see oh look
at that whoa this is hard man come on
Tim hey is his name Timmy
it was something else whatever come on
[ __ ] I have the worst kid it was all the
child's fault shut up okay here we go to
the top baby [ __ ] oh the sound the guy a
crack with my leg you'll pay for this
Timmy look at the body are you okay back
there boy oh well we got rid of him now
I can finally get a handicap parking
this is great this is great this is safe
this is the moment we all waited for
I've waited 84 years to go yeah [ __ ] are
you kidding me oh my child is with me
well that was anticlimactic survived the
turrets are you serious
don't be a [ __ ] [ __ ] here we go boy
never mind really nailed that really oh
my god this can be crazy
[ __ ] you [ __ ] Oh
miss man oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ] everywhere
oh yeah we gotta go slow here we go
I'm scared oh we ditch the bait can't
hit me nothin kick gosh oh that a really
hurt I think I broke my arm in Finnish
that's awesome this game is so fun just
a nice family home ride we're being
attacked by sea salt no no can't hit me
hit my child don't hit me it's just my
leg don't need that to ride a bike
that's why I have two of them don't
worry about it now eat my leg boy oh my
god it's going a little fast
oh there's turrets there's freakin
turrets backflip
oh my god that was the coolest trick
ever only your mom saw that nice I
called that one break my leg it's aw
[ __ ] and kill my child
oh I'm genuinely enjoying playing this
game it's okay oh god oh god I just got
you got shot in the head
Timmy yeah ow ow ow ow [ __ ] my life now
[ __ ] sake not these ah son of a [ __ ]
stop oh there's mine oh my god there's
mines everywhere that's okay speed I'm
steady speed oh god there's mines
everywhere there's mines everywhere
Jesus no we can make oh [ __ ] you Jimmy
Jimmy suck it we got the crazy maps now
[ __ ] hell dude there's mines
everywhere Jimmy's gone my only shield
of defense is gone I got an arrow
through my genitalia and oh [ __ ] that's
gonna hurt tomorrow everything's fine I
could actually do this front flip that
was awesome
with me okay
that's all guts and glory has to offer
right now it looks like a very promising
game remember this is pre-alpha it's a
very early game if you're interested
about the game I'm gonna leave some link
in the description really cool stuff and
if you enjoyed this video please do
leave a like and I'll see you bros in
the next one as always stay awesome bros
make that [ __ ] thing oh my god you
Swedish they're after me